[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
85 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
very, very, very well.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I am
very, very, very well,
too and-- yeah-- in San
Francisco for the last day
before GopherCon.
Very, very, very, very
excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It'll be good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And also very excited
about really cool project.
I love open source.
And we've been talking
about, like, Kubernetes.
We've been talking
about Prometheus.
about so many projects
that are related somehow to
the Cloud Native Computing
Foundation.
And this one is not
yet there, but--
MARK MANDEL: Maybe soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think it will be.
We're going to have the luck
to talk to Varun Talwar, which
is a product manager of
Istio, and Sven Mawson, which
is one of the software
engineers working there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Super excited to have
them on the podcast
to talk about how Istio, one
of the first Kubernetes native
projects--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I love that.
So not even even cloud native.
It's Kubernetes native now.
MARK MANDEL: Kubernetes
native-- yeah-- projects
to help with micro
services, and help
you manage and
administrate them,
and basically do all the stuff
that everyone kind of needs
to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
at the end, we'll
actually have a question
of the week related
to Istio, which
is, OK, so I want
to use Istio on my
Kubernetes cluster.
I already have an application.
What's the best
way to get started?
And there's actually a very
good solution that was created.
So we'll just talk about that.
But before that, we have a bunch
of cool things of the week.
So why don't we go
with them first?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So the first one coming
up is a gentleman
by the name of-- or
I assume gentleman--
a person of note whose
name is Vadim Solavei.
I think I got that
vaguely right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
According to his picture,
he has a beard, so yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's a guy.
Yeah.
The gSlack thing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So he wrote a blog post
stepping through a thing
called gSlack,
integrating Google Cloud
Platform with Slack, which was
basically set up so that there
was a bot that will tell
you when things happen
inside your Google
Cloud Platform project.
So if you want nice
visibility across your project
inside Slack, he shows
how you can set up,
essentially, Stackdriver
logging, going to Pub/Sub,
then going to some
cloud functions
to filter which notifications
you want to receive,
and then finally pushing
that into a select channel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: It's a really
nice little article.
And I think if-- yeah,
if I had a team that
was doing a bunch of stuff on
Google Cloud Platform project,
I think this would be a really
nice way of giving them just
visibility of what's happening.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Lots
of people use Slack.
I've seen many
integrations where
you do things through Slack.
So you deploy Kubernetes
cluster with Slack or whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But I like this one
because it's actually
the other way around.
It's basically
Google Cloud Platform
letting you know
that something's
weird with your Slack
project or whatever,
or that everything is fine.
MARK MANDEL: Everything is fine,
or just somebody did a thing.
Hey, somebody deployed
to Kubernetes,
or somebody pushed
data to datastore,
or whatever it is you
want to know about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I like it.
Very, very cool.
Next, we have also a blog
post explaining how to--
so it's a solution on the
Google Cloud Platform blog,
not podcast.
And it explains how they
built connected vehicle apps
with Cloud IoT Core.
I did not know what
Cloud IoT Core was.
In actually, we just
sent an invite to someone
by the name of Gabe-- hey, Gabe.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Gabe.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We want
to have you for the podcast
to talk about Cloud IoT Core.
But basically, what
Cloud IoT Core does,
it allows you to not
only do data ingestion
from IoT devices, but also
manage the devices themselves.
So all the part--
the authentication,
authorization, but even, like,
updating the software running
on those devices themselves,
is managed by this firmware.
So it's really cool.
And they explain how,
using this and MQTT, which
is kind of a message
queue that we
use to send in stuff to Cloud
Pub/Sub and Cloud Dataflow,
you're basically getting, like,
how to manage those vehicles,
and then how to ingest all of
the data that's coming from it.
It is very cool.
It is very intense.
Like, there's basically
every single--
you have App Engine, Compute
Engine, Container Engine,
Cloud Storage, Bigtable, Cloud
Dataflow, BigQuery, TensorFlow,
Cloud Data Flow,
again, and Pub/Sub.
MARK MANDEL: Bingo.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay.
Oh, and IoT Core too, of course.
MARK MANDEL: Oh of course, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So a very interesting use
case covering a lot of ground.
So go check it out
if you're into IoT
or if you're just curious
about how we can do
cool things with lots of data.
And then we have a cool thing
of the week, which is, you know,
not necessarily
technology related.
But I'm going to
let you go with it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So there is a
wonderful gentleman
here in this SFO office by
the name of Bill Prynne.
Bill, how are you doing?
He regularly posts-- writes
these jokes on the wall
in the office as you walk in.
And today was fantastic.
It was, why did the gopher spend
so much time at the drugstore?
Because he didn't
believe in generics.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is
so bad but I like it.
MARK MANDEL: I had to share
it because it was fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is really good.
I saw it this morning when I got
to the office and I was like,
OK, OK, I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Very good.
I think maybe, if Bill keeps on
cracking up these good jokes,
maybe we should start
using them as part
of the section, the
joke of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Joke of the
week Yeah, I like it.
I like it.
Finally, though, we
have a very short video.
If anyone is
familiar with Mario--
and I'm sure many
of you are-- there's
a mobile application that came
out a little while ago called
Super Mario Run that
was quite popular.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: It was
actually running
on Google Cloud Platform.
And there was a
short video that was
made about how that
was put together
and the team that made
it at Nintendo and DNA,
products they used at GCP.
It's a very short-- it's like
two minutes worth of video--
but it's subtitled.
So if you don't know
Japanese, it's totally fine.
But it's a super
cute video, where you
get to see Mario run around.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
not only that, but you
also get to see the engineers
actually using Google Cloud
Platform.
And you can see they're
managing all the monitoring
with Stackdriver.
They're using BigQuery
to run queries
to see how the
analytics are doing
and extract deeper information.
It's really cool.
And then there's
Mario jumping around.
So you know, you cannot
go wrong with Mario.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
Awesome.
Well, why don't we go have
a chat with Varun and Sven,
and talk to them about Istio?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
So I am very happy to welcome
today two members of the Istio
team working from Mountain
View, joining from Sunnyvale,
I think.
We have Varun Talwar.
Hello, Varun.
How are you doing?
VARUN TALWAR: Hey.
I'm doing well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we
also have Sven Mawson.
How are you doing, Sven?
SVEN MAWSON: Doing great.
Good to be here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
Thank you for coming.
So before we get started talking
about what Istio is-- and I
will be asking
the question, what
does it actually
mean, like that word?
Because, you know, we love
Greek words now in the cloud.
Why don't we talk a little
bit about who you are
and what you do?
Let's start with Varun.
We had you for episode 15 of
the podcast talking about gRPC.
What are you up to now
VARUN TALWAR: Hey, Francesc.
Good to be back.
Besides gRPC, I'm now working on
this new project called Istio,
and very excited to be
talking to you guys about it.
And hopefully, our
listeners are as
excited as we are building it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
you're acting as a product
manager in the team?
VARUN TALWAR: Yes.
I'm a product manager in
Google Cloud and working
on open source.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
What about you, Sven?
SVEN MAWSON: Yeah.
I'm one of the founders
of the Istio project.
I'm a software engineer.
I've been working in the
API management and service
management space at
Google for awhile
and managing the team
delivering Istio.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
So why don't we get started
with the basic question?
So from a high
level, what is Istio?
Varun, you're the PM.
Why don't we see if we can get
a good explanation out of you?
VARUN TALWAR: All right.
Happy to do it.
Let's see if I can do it.
Istio is an open platform to
connect, manage, and secure
services.
That's what you would
read, even if you
go to our website, istio.io.
Essentially, it's an
open service mesh,
where we would like developers
and operators to not
have headaches about
how to connect services,
how to think about making them
resilient, how to secure them,
and how to manage the runtime.
We would like Istio
to be able to do
that for developers
and operators
across all environments
and clouds.
And when I say "services," it's
really all kinds of services,
not necessarily just micro.
It could be anything
you're building--
MySQL API service, a
really small micro service
within your app for payments or
shopping in any given language.
So Istio takes an
approach of working
with polyglot environments.
You know, no matter
what language you
write your services in and
no matter where you deploy,
Istio would like to give
you a uniform substrate
between your application
and network, which
can take care of connectivity
between services,
resiliency between services.
So resiliency includes things
like retries, failover,
all of the good stuff
and distributed systems.
Securing services.
We think internal
services should
be as secure as external
ones, so security by default.
And have complete
observability and visibility
of metrics all the way from L3
to L7 across all your services.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So that sounds like
a great description
from that point of view
of product manager.
You mentioned, at
the first description
that you gave of the
whole project set,
was something about
a service mesh.
What does it mean to
be a service mesh?
What is a mesh?
VARUN TALWAR: So it's
a fairly new term,
so it's worth
explaining what that is.
Essentially, think
about a layer--
and some people call
it the L5 layer,
which is basically a layer
between your application
and your network.
And when you think about it,
you are basically creating--
we are injecting a proxy
next to every service.
And those are in the data
path of all the service
to service communication.
And they are all
interconnected, and also
connected to a
common control plane.
And that interconnected set of
proxies which are living next
to every service is
what typically is being
called as the service mesh.
The reason it's
so interesting is
that once you think of
mesh as a layer which
exists like a network does, you
can, at the application layer,
start to offload things like
connectivity, resiliency,
security, visibility
to that layer.
So historically, you would
do this in either application
libraries.
So if we're building in
Java or Python or Go,
there's a bunch of libraries
in each of these language
environments that you would
import and build logic
into those.
And/or you would do L3
level security and policy,
like IP whitelisting,
firewalling, VPN-ing,
VPC peering, and so on.
So we think service mesh
is a space between the two
which can offload a
few things from L7
and give policy-driven controls
to operate your network.
MARK MANDEL: So
the service mesh is
kind of the bit that's
between everything.
It's kind of like the dark
matter of the universe.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
Haven't described
it that way yet.
MARK MANDEL: So
surface mesh isn't
all the different services
that talk to each other,
but instead the piece
that sits between them
and makes sure that everything
goes OK between all of them.
Would that be about right?
VARUN TALWAR: Yes.
It's the piece that makes
sure that, if you think
all your services as
sort of nodes in a graph,
mesh is basically making
sure you don't have to think
about managing the edges.
And everything that you have
to do on the edges, which
is, how do I connect them?
How do I retry my
connections there?
How do I load balance
my connections there?
How do I apply policy
on my connections?
So that's one way to
understand what the mesh is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're talking a
little bit about level 7,
level 3, level 5.
Just a little bit
for context, I guess,
it's worth mentioning that
I'm assuming you're referring
to the OSI levels of networking,
where level 3 is networking,
level 7 is application.
VARUN TALWAR: That is correct.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What does
it mean level 5 for you?
What does it actually
mean for you?
According to this, it
means session, which
is kind of an ambiguous term.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
Classic OSI stack is
what I'm referring to.
You know, L3 is TCP.
L4 is HTTP.
GRPC also in a similar bucket.
So yeah.
I am saying, I guess,
things above HTTP layer.
Again, L5 is sort of
just a description
to say it's above the network
and below the application.
I don't think it's a formal
concept in the OSI stack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
then from the point
of view of a
developer, basically
it's like, until so far, let's
say that you have two services
and that they're running
on Google Cloud Platform
and Compute Engine or something.
You have two services.
And you want to do
an HTTP request.
One of the services is
exposing a REST API.
So what you normally do is
you just send an HTTP request.
So HTTP woudl be the transport.
Network would be TCP,
whatever goes below.
We don't care.
How does Istio change this?
What is the change in
the whole thing that
allows us to have all the
security and monitoring,
and all that good stuff
you were talking about?
VARUN TALWAR:
Essentially, service A
talking to service B in a
Kubernetes environment, which
is what we have
prioritized Istio today,
but we would hope to take it
to other environments soon.
You would basically
install Istio.
And we would transparently
intercept the A to B traffic.
We would deploy what we call
sidecar proxies, or basically,
proxies next to A and B,
just to keep it simple.
And all A to B communication
then becomes the local proxy A
to local proxy B communication.
And once you do
that, and once Istio
has intercepted the
traffic, the proxies
are smart to do resiliency
things like retries,
circuit breaking, failovers.
And once Istio is
intercepting the traffic,
you can apply
policies like, hey,
don't make more than 100
calls per minute from A to B,
or a rate limit, or a quota.
You could also do load
balancing between A and B
without the applications
having to do anything.
You could get all the
telemetry between A and B
in terms of latency, error
rate, QPS between A and B
without the applications
having to import and wire
in monitoring libraries,
which you would typically do.
Sven, you want to
expand on that?
SVEN MAWSON: Sure.
Yeah.
So the way I think
about this is that Istio
is sort of making your
network a lot smarter.
So from an application view,
you don't have to know about all
of the stuff that's going on.
It's just suddenly, your
network now is more resilient
because you get all these
retries and circuit breaking
and the things Varun
was talking about.
And you get all these policies.
You don't have to actually
go and write any code
to do any of that, right?
It's just sort of automatic.
And under the hood, yeah, we're
adding these sidecar proxies
and we're intercepting traffic.
But that's sort of the
implementation detail
that could change in
future versions of this.
The idea is really just we want
to make the network operate
at the service level, at
the application level,
and be able to do a
lot of these things
that people are
having to write custom
code in their
application to do today.
The network should basically
handle that for them.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And Varun, I mean, you
touched on this a little bit.
You said there was a
priority for Kubernetes.
I've heard this referred to
as Kubernetes native, which
I kind of think is quite cute.
Why-- and Sven, you might
answer this best-- why
was that decision made to
prioritize Kubernetes and make
that the base
platform for Istio?
SVEN MAWSON: So there's sort
of a couple different parts
to that.
One is that we were sitting very
close to the Kubernetes folks.
So that made it easy to
talk to them about problems
we were having.
More seriously, Kubernetes
provides a lot of value
and provides a lot
of services that we
didn't have to go implement.
So it provides a service
registration mechanism,
and orchestration, and
all these other pieces.
It even actually has some
built-in authentication
that we're taking advantage of.
So it really helped us get
to market a lot quicker
with this project because it
had all those pieces we didn't
have to rebuild ourselves.
So that was a big
part of why Kubernetes
was sort of the first target.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
OK, so let's talk
practically, then.
So say I'm a developer.
This sounds really cool.
I don't want to write
all this retry logic
myself or do all this
security stuff myself.
I want to install Istio
and have a play with it.
How do I do that?
How do I make this thing
work with my applications?
SVEN MAWSON: If you're
running on Kubernetes,
you can just go to
istio.io and go to the--
we have sort of a
tutorial section.
And one of those tutorials
is Installing Istio.
It takes about 5 to 10 minutes.
You can install it
in your cluster.
And then there's a
bunch of actual sort
of walkthroughs of
different things
you can do with it after that.
So you play with the routing.
You can play with
policy enforcement.
Authentication actually,
you don't really
have to do anything.
It just automatically secures
your communication for you.
But then if you want
to write policies
against who is acting in
your mesh, you can do that.
So it's actually pretty easy.
I'm sort of surprised
every time I go and do
a demo kind of how easy it is
to get started with this thing.
It's really, really
just 10 minutes
to get something
useful up and running.
MARK MANDEL: And then if I
want to configure Istio--
like you were
talking about being
able to set up connectivity
or load balancing-- how do I
go about doing that?
SVEN MAWSON: Right.
So Istio comes with a command
line tool called Istio Control
that users familiar with
Kubernetes kube control,
it's very similar to that.
It's sort of modeled on it.
Basically, you do the same
thing you would with Kubernetes.
You write a file, and
then you run Istio Control
and pass it the
name of the file.
And it goes in and
configures Istio.
And so that's how you'll do
things like set up a quota.
So you can get a file that says,
user A calling service B only
gets 100 QPS.
That's maybe one or two
lines of configuration.
You run Istio Control.
And now that will
actually be enforced.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And with this, you really
get things like quota,
as we were talking, things
like retrying in case
the service is down.
What about the monitoring?
Is it a dashboard there?
Does it integrate with
other services like--
I don't know-- like Stackdriver?
How does this work?
SVEN MAWSON: Right.
So one of Istio's
philosophies is
that we don't want to build
things other people have built.
So we didn't build any
monitoring ourselves, right?
We're using other
monitoring systems.
The first one we
support is Prometheus.
We've sort of gone with
out-of-the-box Prometheus
support, out-of-the-box a
Prometheus dashboard, actually,
that will automatically
show you all your services,
and their traffic, and errors,
and a bunch of other useful
things.
And there's sort of metrics
that we collect by default.
And then you go and extend that
as a user and add more metrics,
add better dashboards,
add alerts,
whenever you want to do.
VARUN TALWAR: Just wnat to
add what this tier gives
you is more traffic
signals, more L7
metrics into the systems
that you're already
using for monitoring.
So back to our example,
A talking to B. Yes,
you're interested in how much
CPU utilization and network
bandwidths and resources
being used by NB.
But you're probably
more interested in what
is the latency from A to B?
What is the error
rate between A and B?
How many response
[INAUDIBLE] by percentage?
So the things at L7 that you're
interested in you sort of just
get out-of-the-box.
MARK MANDEL: I'm actually
very specifically thinking
of that example where
I would probably
have had of some sort
of try catch error
code on both sides
of my application
that would have caught
that error, either sending
or receiving, and then sent that
up to some sort of monitoring
unit.
But now with Istio, I
can put this in between,
and it's going to handle
that sort of thing
for me, which
sounds really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I just wanted to mention
that, for our listeners,
for more context on Prometheus,
we actually released an episode
with one of the founders of
the project, Julius Volz,
with episode 82.
So if you want to know more
about it, go check it out.
MARK MANDEL: So I was going
to ask another question,
since we also have Varun here.
I know there's some--
I don't want to call it magic.
There's some special
bits and pieces in there
that are particular
that are for gRPC
as well that sort of
work out of the box.
Can you talk about
some of those?
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
So the approach
here is it should
work even if your services
are gRPC services.
So Istio should
work the same way--
hopefully better because
you're getting the HTTP/2
advantages and so on.
So the interesting thing
here is the proxy in Istio
understands gRPC.
So basically, you don't have
to do any transcoding from REST
to gRPC.
You don't have to do that
heavy lifting because the proxy
understands them.
So our goal here is
Istio as such works
with the gRPC services as well.
Of course, in future, we
can make it even better,
that you can have the
policies you apply
and, you know, security
principles you apply.
They can work with two gRPC
services even without proxy.
So we are not there yet.
But I think our goal
is to enable people
to have all these capabilities.
If you use proxy in the middle
or if you just build with gRPC,
you still get a lot of the
connectivity resiliency
and similar kind of traffic
management and policies
that Istio supports.
MARK MANDEL: And won't
Istio also do gRPC
to REST conversion as well?
SVEN MAWSON: It will eventually.
It doesn't quite yet.
MARK MANDEL: Oh really?
OK.
SVEN MAWSON: It's
on our roadmap.
So yes, it will.
MARK MANDEL: I got excited.
I was reading it and
I saw that, and I
was like, oh, that's cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That sounds really interesting.
Actually, since we're
talking about the roadmap--
SVEN MAWSON: Yeah.
We're targetting
the next release.
Yeah, that's actually a feature
that someone in the community
actually created a
gRPC gateway that
does that based on the sort
of standard annotations
that Google released.
And we've also released
a Cloud Endpoints
product that also does this.
And we're very
committed to letting
people write gRPC
services and have
those serve people using gRPC,
but also people just using
HTTP.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So since we're talking about
the roadmap, I wonder--
before we talk
about the roadmap,
is Istio version 1.0 ready?
Is this something that I
should be running in production
not yet?
And if not, when?
SVEN MAWSON: The version
so far is actually 0.1.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's like
1.0, just the other way around.
It's fine.
SVEN MAWSON: Exactly.
The smallest number
we could come up with.
So we don't actually recommend
people use this on production.
The proxy itself, the Envoy
proxy, is production ready.
It's been in
production environments
for at least a year,
if not longer, at Lyft.
But the other pieces are new.
And so if people are
worried about it at all,
they probably shouldn't
rely on it yet.
We're furiously working on more
stability, more performance,
more reliability
of those components
to make sure that
the bar of quality
is much higher on
the next release.
And that's where
we expect people
should sort of have no problems
with using this in production.
That said, I think
there's already
people using this in production
and doing fine with it.
So you know, buyer beware.
But there are people doing that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So please do not use
this in production,
but even though some already do.
That's--
MARK MANDEL: But if
you are, make sure
you submit feedback so that
the product can get better.
SVEN MAWSON: Exactly.
Yes.
Keep the bugs coming.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
then the question
is, what is the roadmap?
When do you think these--
what are the next features
that you're working on?
What should we expect in
the coming months, or maybe
next year?
SVEN MAWSON: Yeah.
So we're actually-- we're
trying to release pretty often.
So we're actually hoping to
get at least two more releases
in this year.
The next release--
so there's a lot
of stability and
performance and sort
of figuring things
out going into that.
So we learned a lot
in the first release.
A lot of it was sort
of duct taped together
to try and just make all the
pieces work, and maybe not
necessarily the sort of
right long term design.
We're trying to finalize,
for example, how
partners and vendors and
other interested parties
can add their own back ends
and their own futures to Istio
and do that very simply.
Today, it's a little bit
harder than we'd like.
So we're doing a lot of
refactoring to clean that up.
Probably the biggest
item in the next release
is actually going to be support
for raw VMs outside Kubernetes,
being able to run this on just
bare VMs, which kind of means
you can run it basically
anywhere, although it will
be more effort than Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is one line.
Raw VMs will take
more because you
have to run all the different
parts yourself, right?
MARK MANDEL: Mhm.
SVEN MAWSON: So that's
probably the biggest piece.
And then after that, hopefully
in the sort of third release,
what I really want
to see is what
we call hybrid,
which is maybe I'm
running a couple different
clusters and some VMs,
and I want all those to be
sort of part of one mesh
and be able to communicate
with each other
and have consistent
authentication
and security and all the
goodness that Istio brings.
That is actually a
very difficult task,
though we're
hopefully up for it.
So hopefully in
the third release,
that will be coming out.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
So actually, that's interesting.
So you mentioned,
Sven, cross cluster.
So does Istio work outside
in, or does it work--
if I have two
Kubernetes clusters
and I want to send
information between them,
I'm guessing the
monitoring is separate
and the aggregation is separate.
But even if I have just
external people using my APIs,
that will still come in
through Istio otherwise.
It's not just internal
to Kubernetes.
SVEN MAWSON: Right.
Yeah.
That's a great question.
So Istio does come with what's
called an ingress controller.
So if you're just
using Kubernetes,
Kubernetes has an
ingress resource
that you configure sort of how
things coming into the cluster
act, really at the
HTTP level only.
And Istio has an
implementation of that
so that the Envoy
proxy basically
acts as that ingress proxy
and secures everything
once it hits that point.
Once things are into the Istio
world, into the Istio mesh,
everything gets secured.
We have that part.
What we don't have yet is sort
of those two clusters sort
of knowing about each other
and being able to do things
like global load balancing
across things and failover
and other sort of--
the really cool stuff you can do
once you know about everything
in both places.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
That sounds really interesting.
Before we finish-- we're
kind of running out of time,
but there is one question
that I said I would ask
and I didn't ask yet, which
is, what does "Istio" mean?
VARUN TALWAR: As you
know, we love Greek words
here at Google Cloud, and they
seem to do well in open source.
So technically, I think
it's "sail" in Greek.
Helmsman, Kubernetes, we're
sort of going with the analogy.
We're not just Kubernetes first.
We also take inspiration
from their naming.
So with that name,
there was another hope
that we would get ist.io.
But we figured that
wasn't available.
And we're soon going
to have stickers.
So it becomes a real project
when you have stickers.
MARK MANDEL: When
you have stickers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And t-shirts.
I'm waiting for one.
MARK MANDEL: T-shirts.
What about t-shirts?
Do we get t-shirts?
VARUN TALWAR: We have
t-shirts already.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
then the web page
for those that would like to
learn more about the project
is istio.io.
SVEN MAWSON: Yes.
Istio.io is the website.
We've tried-- I think there's
decent documentation on getting
started and all that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
I'm just looking at it,
and it's adorable.
SVEN MAWSON: I was just
going to real quick say
that on istio.io, there
is also a lot more
of this sort of
philosophy behind Istio,
as well as just getting started.
So you can learn more
about why we created it,
and how it works, and what
the driving philosophies are
behind it which is all, at least
i think, pretty interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
today to tell us a
little bit about Istio
and get us excited
about the roadmap.
VARUN TALWAR: Awesome.
Thanks for having us.
SVEN MAWSON: Yeah.
It's great to be here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So thanks
again to Varun and Sven
to spend the time to
tell us a little bit more
about Istio, about the
goals and the roadmap,
and a little bit of
the history of it, too.
So very, very interesting
open source project.
And the question of
the week for today
is actually related
to the same topic.
It's about Istio and,
of course, Kubernetes.
And the question is
basically, I use Kubernetes.
I love it.
And I'm already using it
with some applications.
My applications,
I have all the dud
YAMLs to describe the
services and the paths and all
that stuff.
And I want to use Istio.
How do I do this?
Like, what is the best way?
Is there, like,
maybe some tutorial
to explain how to do this?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So this is a really
good question.
So overarching, there is
actually a really great blog
post on the Kubernetes blog--
we'll link to it in the show
notes--
"Managing Micro Services
With the Istio Service Mesh,"
where what it does is it
takes an existing book info
application and then goes
and applies Istio to it
so that you can see metrics
around ingress traffic
in and out and see
how that works.
The thing that it
highlights, and I
think that's kind
of neat, is Istio
comes with Istio CTL,
or Istio Control,
depending on how you like
to pronounce those things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Istio Cuddle.
MARK MANDEL: Istio-- no, no.
Istio CTL.
And one of the commands it has
is a thing called kube-inject.
Basically, the
documentation reads
that the Envoy sidecar that
Istio uses isn't automatically
injected with Istio,
at least not yet.
It's a project in progress, so
they may get there eventually.
But instead, you can use
this kube-inject command
on the Istio CTL where you
can hand it a Kubernetes YAML,
and it will change the
configuration for you.
And basically, you can do that
as many times as you like.
And then, as the
project Istio changes,
which it probably will--
it's still in progress--
you can keep redoing
that to apply that Envoy
sidecar in a canonical way
for Istio going forward.
So essentially, a really
nice little toolkit
showing how you can do things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is interesting.
I think that-- yeah-- the
way they show how to do it
is like Kube CTL apply
of the output of running
Istio CTL kube-inject.
Not a huge fan of that.
I think that probably,
if you're generating
some intermediate YAML, you'd
like to store that somewhere.
MARK MANDEL: You'd
like to keep it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, just in case.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I think you should
keep the original
and what you've generated--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --so you can
always reapply and see
what differences happen.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But other than that,
super cool tool.
If you're getting started
with Istio, have a look at it.
Definitely the blog post, super
interesting, lots of detail.
Just a little
complaint about it.
They show how you can run,
like on the book info,
they get a bunch of
different languages.
So there's models written in
Python, Java, Ruby, and Node.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: What's the problem?
I don't understand.
No problem.
It's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't know.
I don't know.
Yeah, sure.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah.
Other than that, very good.
Very interesting project.
They even describe how,
once this has been done,
you can start seeing
all the graphs
and monitoring on Grafana.
So very, very cool.
Definitely check it out and try
that kube-inject sub-command.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So I believe when
this comes out,
you're going to be at GopherCon?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
By the time this
comes out, I will
be getting ready to teach
my workshop at GopherCon
on performance
analysis of Go programs
using pprof and the Go tracer.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Lots of content in there.
It's going to be fun.
It's going to be a full day of
performance profiling, so yeah.
Fun.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
And speaking of
workshops, I know
you just released one too
that's been doing very well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So I made a video
a long time ago
when I went to Go Con Chicago.
And it was called "Go
Tooling in Action."
And I made a workshop
from it for QCon.
I was in two weeks ago.
And I open sourced the thing.
And it got, like,
1,200 stars on GitHub.
So yeah, I'm famous now.
Yeah.
I made it.
I don't think I'm going to
open source anything else ever
again.
MARK MANDEL: Good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I'm done.
MARK MANDEL: You're done?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep, I'm done.
And also, since we're talking
about things that I've
released lately, I just
released also the latest episode
of "Just for Func."
So I cover how to log stuff
and manage errors and handling
signals and stuff like
that to make programs
that are really robust.
And it's a code review
from a piece of code
that Sandeep wrote--
Sandeep Dinesh from our team.
What about you?
What are you up to?
How is your
open-source life going?
MARK MANDEL: Good.
It's going well.
So I will be at New
York Summit next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Which is cool.
I'll be TA-ing.
There's a Kubernetes
boot camp that's
happening the day before.
So if you're interested
in getting kickstarted
from a basic level what
Kubernetes is doing,
I'll be there helping that out.
There's also an ML and
TensorFlow one that's
also going on on the same day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Is that still
open for people to subscribe?
Will we have a link
in the show notes?
MARK MANDEL: Yes, yes.
Definitely, there will be
a link to the show notes.
It is the day before
VSummit, and there is still
plenty of room for
people to get involved--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: --which is good.
And most recently, I finally
got to the second part of what
apparently is going to be a
five-part blog post series--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: --on
scaling and playing
dedicated game servers
with Kubernetes.
So I just put out one
that's all about how
to manage memory on Kubernetes.
So this may not be necessarily
specific to game servers.
You may find it kind of
interesting if you just like,
how much memory is
my process using,
and should I put limits on
it, and that kind of stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think it's-- regardless of
you're interested in video
games or specifically
paddle soccer--
I think it is very interesting
and shows basically
how to monitor how much
memory, how much CPU you
have in your cluster,
which is cool.
Rather than having
it per pod, you
can also see, like,
a little bit more,
a bigger idea of what the
whole cluster is up to.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
But also, like, if
you're like, I don't even
know how much memory my pod's
using, like, it's very nice,
which is useful.
Awesome.
Well, Francesc,
thank you once again
for joining me for a wonderful
episode of the Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]